taking action for a better tomorrow a
local teen is running a non-profit to
help the community decrease its carbon
footprint Good Day Las Vegas reporter
Candace Charles explains how they plan
to teach the Next Generation
I'm sure a lot of people have food waste
in their homes or just things that they
weren't able to eat in time so why not
use it to make a difference
seventeen-year-old jessalyn Chao wants
to show you how
I don't think many people realize how
big of a change you can make out of
Grassroots level she and her friend Coco
Kang started project green CTA a
non-profit aimed at inspiring the
community to become environmentally
sustainable to address climate change
our goal is to mobilize the youth and
the local community
using a five thousand dollar Grant they
received from non-profit the dragon Kim
Foundation challeng are partnering with
UNLV to host a composting camp for
children 8 to 12. they basically get to
learn about environmental advocacy and
they also get to take home their own
composting kit the lunch and learn is
one of the ways ciao tells me she hopes
it'll help Nevada families realize that
the climate crisis is not Out Of Reach I
really hope that they get to realize how
even at the age of eight or nine or ten
that you can really do something to make
a difference the West Career and
Technical Academy rising seniors are
taking many big steps to creating a
smaller carbon footprint and help to
encourage everyone to step up their
efforts to do the same
big change starts small Kansas Charles 8
News Now
project green cta's launch and learn
will take place on Friday at the UNLV
lead library from one to four free lunch
composting kits and a raffle will be
included as well to find out more about
project green CTA head to 8newsnow.com